- THIS ONE'S
FOR ALL THE LADIES.
♪ IF YOU WANT TO EAT ANIMALS ♪
♪ I CAN'T STOP YOU ♪
♪ BUT YOU MUST KNOW ♪
♪ YOU ARE NEVER GONNA FEEL ♪
♪ MY [BLEEP] ON YOUR CLIT ♪
[BRIGHT ACOUSTIC GUITAR MUSIC
PLAYING]
♪ IF YOU WANT TO EAT ANIMALS ♪
♪ I CAN'T STOP YOU ♪
♪ BUT YOU MUST KNOW ♪
♪ I AM NEVER GONNA STICK
♪ MY [BLEEP] UP YOUR ASS ♪
♪ ♪
♪ I'M NOT GAY ♪
♪ BUT I'D RATHER SUCK ♪
♪ A VEGAN [BLEEP] ♪
♪ THAN LICK A CARNIST [BLEEP] ♪
♪ ♪
GO VEGAN!
[STRUMS]
- ALL RIGHT,
HE IS IN NO POSITION
TO BE PICKY ABOUT
WHO HE GOES DOWN ON.
THAT PUSSY [BLEEP] ACTIVIST
IS JOHN.
HE MAKES LOTS OF MUSIC VIDEOS,
AND LIKE EVERYTHING VEGANS DO,
THEY'RE A BIT JUDGE-Y
AND OFF-PUTTING.
A VEGAN WITH AN ACOUSTIC GUITAR
IS THE ABSOLUTE LAST PERSON
I WOULD EVER INVITE TO A PARTY.
LIKE AUTISM AND PANIC ATTACKS,
VEGANISM IS SOMETHING
WHITE PEOPLE INVENTED
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
REAL PROBLEMS.
VEGANS CLAIM IT'S ALL ABOUT
PREVENTING SUFFERING,
BUT NOBODY SUFFERS MORE
THAN THE GUY
CHOKING DOWN CASHEW CHEESE.
JUST STOP TRYING TO CONVERT US.
THIS ISN'T CHRISTIANITY.
YOU DON'T GET TO GO
TO A SPECIAL VEGAN HEAVEN.
AND DON'T GET THEM
CONFUSED WITH VEGETARIANS.
VEGETARIANS WILL STILL USE SOAP
TO WASH THEIR BODIES.
IS THERE DAIRY IN THIS?
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M NOT A FORENSIC SCIENTIST.
IT TASTES GOOD,
SO PROBABLY, YES.
AND IF YOU SHOW UP
TO MY SUPER BOWL PARTY
WITH CAULIFLOWER BUFFALO WINGS,
I WILL PUNCH YOU
IN THE THROAT.
JUST SIT THERE HOGGING
ALL THE CELERY
WHILE YOU TRY
TO FIGURE OUT FOOTBALL.
PERSONALLY, I DON'T CARE
WHAT JOHN PUTS IN HIS BODY,
AS LONG AS HE KEEPS MAKING
HIS SWEET, SWEET MUSIC.
THAT'S WHY I FLEW HIM
TO HOLLYWOOD,
WHERE THE ONLY DIET
MORE POPULAR THAN GOING VEGAN
IS BULIMIA,
FOR THIS WEEK'S
CE-WEB-RITY PROFILE.
[UPBEAT ACOUSTIC GUITAR MUSIC]
♪ ♪
ONE RADISH SANDWICH,
HEAVY ON THE I CAN BELIEVE
IT'S NOT BUTTER
ON 1,000-GRAIN BREAD.
- THANK YOU.
- THAT'LL BE $24. NEXT!
- UH, FOOT-LONG
MEATBALL HOAGIE WITH BACON.
♪ ♪
- GO ON AND GET,
YOU HETEROSEXUAL CARNIST
SON OF A BITCH!
JOHN!
- HEY.
- HOW YOU DOING, BUDDY?
- HOW ARE YOU?
- WHAT CAN I
GET YOU TODAY?
- CAN I GET
A 1/2 POUND OF TOFU,
EXTRA THIN?
- YOU GOT IT.
♪ ♪
[WHIRRING]
IS THAT THIN ENOUGH
FOR YOU?
ANY THINNER, IT REALLY
GUNKS UP THE SLICER.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU
BEEN A VEGAN?
- I'VE BEEN VEGAN
SINCE 1998
AFTER READING A BOOK CALLED
"OLD MACDONALD'S FACTORY FARM."
- IS THERE ANY SCENARIO
WHERE YOU CAN EAT
MILK, EGGS, OR DAIRY?
LIKE, WHAT IF YOU HAD
YOUR OWN COW?
- YEAH, IF YOU HAD
YOUR OWN COW
OR IF YOU HAD
RESCUED CHICKENS.
THE WAY I LOOK
AT IT IS THAT
THERE'S NO CONSENT
INVOLVED.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH THE HENS AND ASK,
BUT IF I WERE
IN A SITUATION--
SAY IF I WERE
AT AN ISLAND SOMEWHERE
WITH ME AND A CHICKEN
AND I HAD TO,
I WOULD KILL AN ANIMAL AND EAT
THE ANIMAL TO SURVIVE,
BECAUSE THE WILL TO LIVE
IN ME IS VERY, VERY STRONG.
- CAN YOU TELL
THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A CARNIST VAGINA
AND A VEGAN VAGINA?
- I PROBABLY COULDN'T.
I'D HAVE TO DO A TASTE TEST,
MAYBE, BACK AND FORTH,
BECAUSE THEY'D PROBABLY
TASTE VERY SIMILAR.
- MM-HMM.
- REALLY, I'VE BEEN SO BUSY
DOING MY ART AND ACTIVISM
THAT I HAVEN'T EVEN BEEN
WITH A WOMAN
IN TWO YEARS NOW.
- BY CHOICE?
- WELL, I HAVE SOME WOMEN
WHO ARE INTERESTED IN ME,
BUT I GUESS I'VE
JUST BEEN BUSY.
- BUT IF YOU WERE ON AN ISLAND
WITH A CARNIST WOMAN,
YOU WOULD HAVE
NO PROBLEM KILLING HER?
- IF SHE DIED, MAYBE I'D EAT
HER BODY, YOU KNOW, TO SURVIVE.
- I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYTHING WRONG WITH THAT.
- NO.
- CAN BEING A VEGAN
REALLY MAKE YOU
PERFORM BETTER
IN THE BEDROOM?
- I THINK SO BECAUSE
CHOLESTEROL CLOGS ARTERIES.
YOU HAVE ARTERIES IN
YOUR PENIS, FOR INSTANCE,
AND SO YOU INGEST
THE CHOLESTEROL,
AND IT CAN CAUSE
ERECTILE DYSFUNCTION.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM
GETTING AN ERECTION
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT,
SO...
- ME NEITHER.
- GOOD.
- I'LL RACE YOU.
- [LAUGHS]
- I HEARD YOU WROTE A SONG
ABOUT ME OR FOR ME.
- I DID. YES.
- DO I GET TO HEAR THAT?
- ABSOLUTELY.
I'LL EVEN THROW IN SOME
PELVIC THRUSTING FOR YOU.
[LAUGHS]
- SEEMS LIKE A BONUS.
I'LL TAKE IT.
- ♪ DANIEL "TOSH.0" ♪
♪ IT'S TIME TO GO ♪
BOTH: ♪ VEGAN ♪
♪ VEGAN ♪
♪ DANIEL "TOSH.0" ♪
♪ IT'S TIME TO GO ♪
♪ VEGAN ♪
♪ LET'S MAKE SOME
PLATES AND DANCE ♪
♪ AND MAYBE GET TOGETHER ♪
♪ FOR SOME ROMANCE ♪
♪ WITH SOME SEXY VEGANS ♪
♪ SEXY VEGANS ♪
♪ VEGANS ARE SEXY ♪
♪ YEAH, YEAH, YEAH ♪
- THAT IS A GOOD SONG.
THE PART WHERE YOU GOT
REAL--FLIRTATIOUS THING,
THAT WAS A LITTLE SCARY,
BUT I LIKED IT.
- THE WHOLE POINT
OF THAT SONG WAS
DON'T USE ANIMALS
AS INSULTS.
- YEAH, LIKE, FOR INSTANCE,
I'VE SEEN LOTS OF VIDEOS
ON THE INTERNET
OF POLICE BRUTALITY,
FOR INSTANCE,
AND SO PEOPLE WILL
CALL POLICE PIGS.
- SURE.
- BUT THE PIGS I'VE MET ARE
REALLY AWESOME CREATURES.
- MAYBE BEING CALLED A PIG
IS A COMPLIMENT,
'CAUSE I THINK WHEN
I CALL A COP A PIG...
- YEAH.
- HE SHOULD TAKE THAT AS,
"OH, I'M A VERY INTELLIGENT
FARM ANIMAL."
- YEAH, WE DON'T EVEN NEED
TO INSULT PEOPLE WHATSOEVER.
I THINK IT'S BETTER TO SAY
WORDS THAT BUILD PEOPLE UP.
- OKAY, WHAT IF I SAY YOU'VE
GOT, LIKE, A HORSE'S [BLEEP].
- [LAUGHS]
I WOULD TAKE THAT
AS A COMPLIMENT, SURE.
- SO SHOULD ONLY A PIG BE
ALLOWED TO CALL SOMEONE A PIG?
LIKE, BLACK PEOPLE
ARE THE ONLY PEOPLE
THAT ARE ALLOWED
TO USE THE N WORD?
- YES, I USED THE N WORD
IN A VIDEO ONCE,
AND SOMEONE SAID TO ME,
"JOHN, YOU KNOW,
WHITE PEOPLE
CAN'T SAY THAT,"
SO I DELETED THE VIDEO,
AND I DON'T SAY IT ANYMORE.
- HUH.
YOU LEARNED YOUR LESSON.
- I LEARNED MY LESSON.
ONE TIME, I EVEN WENT
IN BLACKFACE
'CAUSE I WAS TIRED OF
ALWAYS HAVING WHITE PEOPLE
IN MY VIDEOS, 'CAUSE I'LL
PLAY ALL THE CHARACTERS.
- JOHN, THAT IS A BAD IDEA.
- I KNOW.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
FUN TO HAVE A BLACK WOMAN,
SO I PUT MAKEUP ON,
AND I WAS VERY RESPECTFUL
WITH THE CHARACTER.
- SURE, YOU WERE.
- SHE WAS INTELLIGENT
AND EVERYTHING.
BUT PEOPLE SAID,
"JOHN, YOU KNOW,
"THERE'S A BAD HISTORY
WITH BLACKFACE,
SO DON'T DO THAT AGAIN."
- I DON'T KNOW
WHERE YOU WERE LIVING
FOR THE PAST 45 YEARS,
BUT...
- I KNOW. WELL, YEAH,
I MADE A BIG MISTAKE.
- WILL YOU SEND US
THAT BLACKFACE VIDEO?
I PROMISE I WON'T PUT IT
ON TELEVISION.
- OR SHARE--
YOU CAN'T SHARE IT
WITH ANYONE ON THE INTERNET,
EITHER. IT'D BE FOR--
- NO, I JUST WANT
TO WATCH IT MYSELF.
- YEAH, UH, SURE.
- THE ANSWER'S NO.
YOU SHOULD NOT EVER SEND
THAT VIDEO EVER AGAIN.
- OKAY.
- YOU'LL GET YOURSELF
IN A LOT OF TROUBLE.
HAS THERE EVER BEEN
ANY PUSHBACK
FROM THE VEGAN COMMUNITY?
- YES, THEY SAY I MAKE VEGANS
LOOK LIKE WEIRDOS.
- ARE YOU MAKING
ANY MONEY OFF THESE VIDEOS?
- A LITTLE BIT.
I'VE MADE 700 BUCKS.
- OVER HOW LONG?
- FOUR YEARS.
- ALL RIGHT, THAT'S NOT--
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH
TO LIVE OFF OF.
JOHN, IF YOU ASK ME,
PETA'S GONE TOO SOFT,
WASTING THEIR TIME WITH
ALL THESE NUDE PHOTO SHOOTS.
EVERYONE KNOWS
MEAT IS MURDER.
THERE'S ONLY ONE WAY
TO STOP MURDER,
AND THAT'S
WITH MORE MURDER.
SAYS SO RIGHT IN THE BIBLE.
I WANT YOU TO MEET ME
BACK HERE AT MIDNIGHT.
- MIDNIGHT?
WHY SO LATE?
- MM, OKAY, 9:30.
[YELLING]
[EERIE MUSIC]
♪ ♪
WE'VE GOT WORK TO DO.
WE HAVE TO CUT THE HEAD
OFF THE SNAKE,
AND THE BODY WILL DIE.
- ♪ NEVER USE THE NAME
OF AN ANIMAL ♪
♪ AS AN INSULT
FOR A HUMAN ♪
- IT'S JUST AN EXPRESSION,
JOHN.
WE'RE NOT KILLING ANY SNAKES.
WE'RE GONNA KILL
THE TOP MEAT PUSHERS.
- I'M NOT GONNA KILL ANYONE.
- YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
WE'VE EACH GOT SPECIAL SKILLS.
YOURS JUST HAPPENS
TO BE PLAYING MUSIC
THAT MAKES PEOPLE WANT
TO KILL THEMSELVES.
FIRST UP, SAM THE BUTCHER.
- FROM "THE BRADY BUNCH"?
- YEAH. YOU KNOW HIM?
- I THINK HE DIED
A WHILE AGO.
- OKAY. ONE DOWN.
- ♪ SLITTING THROATS ♪
♪ STOPPING HEARTS
FROM BEATING ♪
♪ THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT ♪
♪ MEAT IS MURDER ♪
[DRAMATIC ACOUSTIC GUITAR MUSIC
PLAYING]
♪ TAKING A LIFE ♪
♪ WHEN YOU DON'T NEED TO ♪
♪ THAT, MY FRIENDS,
IS MURDER ♪
♪ ♪
♪ YOUR BOLOGNA
HAS A FIRST NAME ♪
♪ IT'S M-U-R-D-E-R ♪
[GUNFIRE]
♪ ANIMALS
DO NOT WANT TO DIE ♪
♪ JUST SO THAT HUMANS
CAN FRY ♪
♪ THEIR BLOODY,
BLOODY CORPSES ♪
♪ MEAT IS MURDER ♪
[GUNSHOT]
♪ CHOKE ON THAT,
YOU FAKE-ASS COLONEL ♪
♪ NOW YOU'RE
FINGER-LICKIN' DEAD ♪
♪ IF YOU'RE EATING
BENIHANA'S ♪
♪ I DON'T WANT TO SMELL
YOUR VAGINA ♪
♪ ROUND OF APPLAUSE
FOR MURDER ♪
♪ MURDER ♪
♪ IT'S MURDER ♪
- JA RULE BET ME A GRAND
THAT I COULDN'T GET THAT GUY
TO SAY "MURDER" 12 TIMES.